Speaker 1: We knew when the Supreme Court
overturned Roe v Wade that there would be
further actions when it comes to restricting
access to abortions at the state level. And one
of the battle lines now is trying to essentially
banish abortion pills, as they're called,
medication abortions from pharmacies in all
sorts of states around the country. And there is
now controversy involving involving Walgreens and
some other chains related to this. The relatively
new governor of Massachusetts, Democrat Maura
Healey, has issued a declaration pharmacies
must stock abortion pills. The Associated Press
reports the governor of Massachusetts reminded
pharmacies Wednesday they are required to stock
a key abortion pill despite a nationwide effort
by anti-abortion activists to ban the medication.
The action comes as a federal judge in Texas is
considering a lawsuit that would overturn
decades old federal approval of the drug.
Democratic Governor Maura Healey issued a written
statement saying the pharmacies must maintain,
quote, a continuous sufficient supply
of all family planning medications,
including mifepristone, misoprostol, emergency
contraception and contraceptive prescriptions.
Now, this is great, but there's already very
little problem with abortion access in the
state of Massachusetts. But the most important
takeaway is that this is an action that trying
to block and ban and and prevent these drugs
from being available. This is being carried out
by a political movement that claims to be pro-life
when this is actually an extraordinarily anti-life
thing to be doing. Limiting access to abortion
pills, which is the next sort of battle that
they're fighting now. It's bad health policy
and it's also extraordinarily counterproductive
to their own stated goals. Number one, abortion
pills are a safe and effective way to terminate
pregnancies in their early stages. When you limit
access to these drugs, it can lead to more unsafe
methods of abortion, more dangerous methods
of abortion, and it can delay abortion until
later in the pregnancy, which is never an ideal
thing to look for. It puts the health of women at
risk. It can potentially put the lives of women
at risk. Unsafe abortions are a leading cause of
maternal mortality worldwide. So when you limit
access to the abortion pills, you're essentially
forcing women either to have later abortions or
to have more dangerous abortions. And it's a very
bad thing when you look at the health data. Now,
of course, the people that are against the pills
don't care. And to some degree, they believe if we
limit access to these pills, a lot of these women
simply won't have abortions altogether. But we can
talk about that as well when you limit access to
abortion pills. There's the philosophical issue,
which is you're violating the bodily autonomy of
these women. Women should have the right to have
these tools available and to decide with freedom
and liberty. Is this something I want to use
or not? Let me make a decision about my body
and my health with the doctors. When you limit
access to these medications, you violate that
fundamental principle of freedom, liberty and
bodily autonomy, which these right wingers claim
to defend. But then let's go to the end. Okay.
Think of the economic and social consequences of
this. If you succeed, if you succeed at preventing
abortions by making the pills difficult to access.
Women. If they choose not to have the if
they're unable to have the abortion because
you limit access to these pills, they might
end up carrying to term and ending up with
a child that they were unprepared for or
for whatever reason did not want to have.
You then have a situation where and I know that
this sounds so cold, right? But the economic
impact, you are now going to have individuals
who will lose income due to time off, suffer
economic hardships, people who have children that
they don't want to have. The outcomes aren't good
for the parents and they're not not good for
the kids. And so then you lose the economic
productivity of that person. It sounds crazy
to even be talking about it, but this is part
of their entire thing. If if that's something
you care about, then your actions in trying to
ban these pills are counterproductive. Not to
mention for those pregnant mothers who do have
the ability to go to another state, for example,
to obtain the pills or obtain a surgical abortion.
Now they are going to have to take time off. And
that's going to have an economic impact as well.
So no matter what you care about, whether you care
about philosophy and ethics, liberty and freedom,
whether you care about safety, whether you care
about economic product, whatever you care about.
Trying to prevent access to these
medications makes no sense whatsoever